for more on the pros and cons of
Hamburg's smart harbor i'm joined by
sandro giken from the european school of
management and technology good to have
you here with us now we just in this one
report and there was one sentence that
stuck out for me at least it said
traffic congestion hasn't improved do
you think this pilot project failed or
is it too soon to judge I think it's a
bit too soon to judge maybe they will it
takes a long time to optimize these IT
processes on to the specific
implementation they're having and
something like the a big harbor is
really very unique so it's not a
standard business application where you
know exactly what you do but still most
of the promises we get from IT companies
regarding efficiency regarding the
better quality of your life of your work
process of everything usually don't live
up to expectations you have a lot of
follow-on costs especially with these
huge complex products and processes like
SI p into such a big harbor you're never
done implementing complexity issues
arise and of course security is a big to
say we heard about the hackers attack of
the antwerp harbor i mean kind of damage
can happen in this case the damage could
be a gigantic i mean it's like you could
live we have new kinds of wiper
malware's which wipe all sorts of data
so you could lose all the data about all
the containers where everything is what
is in there to open up everything and
something like that happening in the
harbor of hamburg could be a big process
now major hacker scandal is in the news
this week's the hacking of Ashley
Madison side and the possible release of
private information from millions of
subscribers and this attack has brought
her once again that data security is a
huge issue for individuals business but
even for the government a hacker attack
on the German parliament the bundestag
earlier this year caused a major scandal
we remember that well nevertheless
despite all those dangers all in all
what would you say are the potentials of
smart data for example for
infrastructure projects there's a
certain potential in infrastructure
project as a German you tend to be more
critical towards these things because we
have very good processes already
analyzing all these things we know a lot
about autumn
we know a lot about infrastructure
project process but still if you know
everything about these projects because
if you generate data everything
everywhere everywhere and you have smart
algorithms giving you the information
you need exactly you could probably
still optimize things and in some cases
like very large projects very exotic
projects this could be of help I just
briefly where does German industry stand
in terms of smart data we know that sa p
is very big when it comes to software
what else well unfortunately we have to
say that Silicon Valley was much faster
than we were of course and so some
Chinese companies are coming in now some
other companies from other regions so so
we're sort of late to the game but on
the other hand we have a unique
knowledge and production and heavy
machinery and these kinds of things so
when it comes to big data smart data in
that particular area I think we still
have a competitive advantage alright
well we'll continue our little chat
Sandberg i can so don't go anywhere okay